this is so scary look at this
I kid so today we're here to play hair
not a video game where apparently I'm
gonna block people from touching my hair
honestly with my natural hair I haven't
really had people try to touch it it's
only what I have brains that people are
touching it and confused and looking at
it like there's snakes hanging from my
scalp there's something about just the
fact that we as black women have so many
varied and creative hairstyles that
people kind of just like see it and dive
on in I have just washed my hair
this girl honestly just grabs the curls
I'm just going like this to them like oh
my god I think it's okay to ask about it
if you ask about it once don't ask about
it again I feel like I'm always linking
the matrix and like I don't like dodging
people like whoa and it's like slow
motion and like the people don't get it
I have heard of hair not I saw it on
Twitter
I saw Shonda Rimes shared it so must be
dope so fun fact never played a video
game before but this I've been trained
for this my whole life
hi I'm below and I am the creator of
hair now I was inspired just by my
experiences in Portland in a minute I
got here everyone was just like oh your
hair it's so nice and they would just be
grabbing it I'd be in a store
Ivy had a gala like it just happened a
lot and I was like what the hell is this
really basically is why I made this game
when I was creating this I just really
wanted people to understand how much in
an invasion of space it is you know I
think that just saying don't touch my
hair doesn't necessarily cover it so
yeah this game is it's in it for
everybody
black on my first survive like be fun
and political like teach some stuff it
makes a friend all right I'm ready 3 2 1
go okay it's time
uh-uh bye girl bye oh my god a lot of
him this was just a while because I'm
picturing just some white dudes sitting
on a stool overlooking my head there's
like a thousand here I'm stressed oh
hell no the minute I started it was like
so fluffy Oh go leave yes yes yes oh my
god yes keep it up cuz you're just
getting started
oh this actually feels like the anxiety
I get when people actually touch my hair
oh can you imagine being an uber or lyft
and you're getting attacked from all
sides that's why I don't if I shouldn't
be pools it's kind of cathartic honestly
to be swatting away these hands because
I've definitely dealt in real life with
multiple people coming up at once and
touching my head or people saying crazy
stuff to me about my hair and thinking
it's okay okay almost okay tell me
something good oh this you did that next
that is body listen the fact that
someone is coming up here to tell you
yes girl yes Oh what I can't talk right
now whew oh no I have five seconds I'm
gonna lose no I am so competitive I'm
not good at losing I'm not oh can I like
the quotes are so real too like it's so
soft is it touch to your head that one
just makes me that one really triggers
me like that makes me the most mad
because I've heard that before it's just
like such a weird ridiculous question
this la I won this round with thirty
thirty seconds left so what I want is
for my boyfriend to play this game and
for him to see how frustrating this is
so this is a black woman in the back
behind me and she's like opening it with
one eye as she's sleeping and just like
frowning on my behalf
maybe I should have went with a shorter
hairstyle
then I couldn't fit oh I did it welcome
to Havana you win the game is over but
this experience isn't this is an issue
that black women face daily so a note to
those who do it stop that [ __ ]
I felt very claustrophobic just watching
it and playing it it was very scary like
I just kept thinking like this is
actually my worst nightmare this was a
dope game I feel like the game was
definitely intended for an audience that
never experiences this so it's a great
way to be like hey this is how you're
making me feel hair not was really
interesting I was saying it's not the
most accurate but sometimes we can say
like please don't touch my hair and it
is an issue and people still don't take
it seriously or take it lightly as if it
doesn't affect people but this is
something that affects people it affects
women of color every single day one of
the most striking things about playing
the game wasn't just the fact that
people were like physically swarming and
it was the comments that they would make
oh it's so soft
oh is this attached to your head it's
things like that - that just really like
resonate because I've had all of those
comments and more shout out to you Momo
this is a great game it teaches people
about our culture about our hair the
do's and don'ts and it's entertaining
this is a dick thing I would play again
but yeah maybe with some alcohol
[Music]